there are lots of different ways to use
science to pursue thrills but here's one
you haven't caught up and definitely
shouldn't try yes that's right Jason
Zhang has been duct-taped to the ceiling
and somehow seems to be enjoying it say
well I'm Phil this is just a typical
night out well we didn't know duct tape
was that strong
so how can I keep 175 pound Jason stuck
to the ceiling what keeps the man stuck
to the ceiling is something called van
der Waals forces now the molecules that
make up the adhesive got big clouds of
electrons in them and it's very easy to
shift these electrons around the
molecule making some parts slightly more
negative and some parts slightly more
positive and this can also happen in the
ceiling so you have a slightly negative
part attracted to a slightly positive
part and vice-versa while each of these
attractions is very small there's
millions of them over the whole surface
area of the tape what that does is it
adds up to be a strong enough force to
be able to hold the student to the
ceiling this doesn't just happen with
adhesive tapes this is actually how
geckos climb smooth surfaces that use
Vander Waals forces as well and remember
don't try this at home
most ceilings will collapse which isn't
thrilling at all